>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON, THEY ACCUSE YOU
THE VERY THING THEY ARE DOING
THEMSELVES.
IF THERE IS ONE RULE YOU CAN
KEEP ON YOUR FRIDGE, WRITE IT
DOWN AND PUT IN YOUR WALLET TO
EVALUATE THE BEHAVIOR OF THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE.
THAT.
THEY BLAME YOU FOR THEIR SINS
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
LATEST EXAMPLE, WE LEARNED JOE
BIDEN FRESH FROM LECTURING HOW
DONALD TRUMP IS A CRIMINAL
BECAUSE HE HAD UNAUTHORIZED
POSSESSION OF SECRET DOCUMENTS,
JOE BIDEN HAD HIMSELF
UNAUTHORIZED SECRET DOCUMENTS,
DON'T WORRY, IT IS NOT A BIG
DEAL.
UNLIKE YOU AND DONALD TRUMP, JOE
BIDEN IS A GOOD PERSON, SO
VIRTUOUS HE'S TRANSCENDED LAW
ISSUE NOT A CRIME WHEN HE DOES
IT.
DETAILS ARE INTERESTING.
WEEK BEFORE THE LAST MID-TERM
ELECTION, JOE BIDEN LAWYERS WERE
ROOTING IN A LOCKED CLOSET IN
THE PAN-BIDEN GLOBAL ENGAGEMENT
AND WHILE IN THE LOCKED CLOSET
BIDEN LAWYER FOUND HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS,
WHY WERE JOE BIDEN'S LAWYERS
DOING THIS IN THE FIRST PLACE?
IT IS WEIRD.
LAWYERS DON'T TYPICALLY SEARCH
LOCKED CLOSETS, YOURS PROBABLY
DON'T.
BIDEN'S LAWYERS DID AND WE GUESS
BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTOOD
REPUBLICANS WERE ABOUT TO WIN
BACK THE HOUSE AND CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENA POWER.
CLEANUP OPERATION TO GET AHEAD
OF A SCANDAL THEY KNEW WAS
COMING AND HID WHAT THEY FOUND
UNTIL AFTER THE MIDTERM
ELECTION, NO REASON TO INFLUENCE
VOTERS WITH INFORMATION, THERE
IS THAT.
THEN THE QUESTION OF PAN-BIDEN
CENTER AT UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, WHAT IS THAT,
EXACTLY?
IDEA OF ACADEMIC BIDEN CENTER IS
FUNNY, JOE BIDEN IS A MORON,
ALWAYS BEEN A MORON, EVEN BEFORE
THE DEMENTIA.
FOR DECADES IN WASHINGTON, BIDEN
WAS FAMOUS AS DUMBEST MEMBER OF
SENATE, PEOPLE MADE JOKES ABOUT
IT.
WHY NAME A THINK TANK AFTER A
MAN WHO CAN'T THINK AND PAY HIM
MILLION A YEAR FOR NOT DOING
ANYTHING?
MORE ON THAT IN A MINUTE.
FIRST A WORD ABOUT CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, PEOPLE YOU SEE
HUFFING AND PUFFING ABOUT VITAL
STATE SECRETS, NOT JUST
DEMOCRATS, EVERYBODY, THEY ARE
EITHER LYING OR DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW WASHINGTON WORKS, HOW MANY
LEGITIMATE VITAL STATE SECRETS
ARE THERE?
NOT MANY AT ALL.
IN DEMOCRACY, THE GOVERNMENT HAS
NO RIGHT TO HIDE WHAT IT IS
DOING FROM THE PUBLIC EXCEPT
UNDER EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT IS NOT FINE TO SPEND 60 YEARS
HIDING THE FACT THE CIA WAS
INVOLVED IN MURDER OF PRESIDENT,
HIDING INVOLVEMENT IN KENNEDY
ASSASSINATION IS A CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR MADE POSSIBLE BY
CLASSIFICATION REGIME DESIGNED
NOT TO PROTECT THIS COUNTRY, BUT
TO PROTECT POLITICAL CLASS,
WHICH IS EFFICIENTLY DOES.
OH, BUT OUR ENEMIES SCREECH THE
MORONES ON TV, IF WE CLASSIFY
THESE DOCUMENTS AND DO THAT, OUR
ENEMIES WILL LEARN OUR SECRETS.
PLEASE.
CHINA KNOWS OUR SECRETS, ALL OF
OUR SECRETS.
CHINESE GOVERNMENT HACKED EVERY
AGENCY IN WASHINGTON AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT AND NOBODY
SEEMS TO CARE.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CARES SO
LITTLE IT SUSPENDED ESPIONAGE
PROGRAM FOR CHINESE SPYING.
CHINESE CAN KNOW, YOU CAN'T
KNOW, BIDEN TRUSTS BEIJING MORE
THAN HE TRUSTS YOU.
JOB IS TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
ATTITUDES LIKE THAT.
REPORTERS ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PAID TO FIND OUT WHAT GOVERNMENT
IS DOING AND TELL YOU ABOUT IT
SO DEMOCRACY CAN CONTINUE.
THERE ARE FEW OF THOSE LEFT.
ED SNOWDEN LIVES IN EXILE.
CONTROLLED BY GOVERNMENT AGENCY
AND SUGGESTION DRIVES THEM TO
4ISTERRIA.
WATCH CNN AND MSNBC, REACT TO
NEWS REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
MIGHT TELL US SOME OF WHAT THE
THOROUGHLY KRUNT INTEL COMPANY
HAS BEEN DOING.
>> REPUBLICANS CAN SHRED AT
INTEGRITY OF FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND TELL AMERICA YOUR GOVERNMENT
IS SPYING ON YOU AND COMING
AFTER YOU, THAT IS AT THE HEART
OF THIS TEAR-DOWN, BREAK DOWN
THE GOVERNMENT, CAN'T TRUST THE
GOVERNMENT, HE GAVE THEM A
COMMITTEE PLATFORM TO HAVE
HEARINGS AND YOU BETTER BELIEVE
THAT IS IN THE VEINS OF FOX NEWS
VIEWERS.
>> THEY ARE ESTABLISHING A
SUB-COMMITTEE OR COMMITTEE ON
WHICH CONSPIRACY THEORIES, THIS
IS SO EXTRAORDINARILY DANGEROUS,
THEY ARE GOING TO ACTUALLY ISSUE
THESE PEOPLE WANT TO TARGET
AMERICA'S INTEL COMMUNITY.
>> THIS IS A BODY OF THE
CONGRESS THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
MAINTAIN CREDIBILITY WITH AND WE
ARE NOT GOING TO DO THAT BY OPEN
UP ALL KINDS OF SUSPICIONS ABOUT
THE INSTITUTIONS IN OUR SOCIETY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT IS OUTRAGEOUS TO TELL
PEOPLE THE GOVERNMENT IS SPYING
ON THEM, ESPECIALLY SINCE THE
GOVERNMENT IS SPYING ON THEM.
THAT IS CONFIRMED, BY THE WAY, A
FACT, THEY SPIED ON US.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
GOVERNMENT IS DO BEING,
TARGETING INTELECOMMUNITY, YOU
ARE DISLOYAL AMERICAN.
THAT IS WHAT MSNBC IS SAYING.
WE LEARNED TWITTER FUNCTIONED AS
MOUTH PIECE FOR THE FBI AND SPY
AGENCY, SAME THING HAS HAPPENED
TO CABLE NEWS AND THAT IS GRAVER
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY THAN ANY
GROUP OF TRUMP VOTERS WHO WERE
AT THE CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6.
BACK TO THE STORY, HILARIOUS
DOUBLE STANDARD ON QUESTION OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, JUST THIS
SUMMER, NBC HISTORIAN MICHAEL
SUGGESTED DONALD TRUMP DESERVE
THE DEATH PENALTY FOR KEEPING
DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO.
FRIED IN THE ELECTRIC CHAIR.
MICHAEL HAYDEN AGREED, SOUNDS
ABOUT RIGHT, TOTALLY NORMAL FOR
CIA DIRECTORS TO FANTASIZE ABOUT
KILLING AMERICAN PRESIDENTS.
FOR FUN, WE REACHED OUT TO
MICHAEL TO ASK WHAT PUNISHMENT
HE THINKS JOE BIDEN DESERVES FOR
KEEPING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN
HIS OFFICE.
OF COURSE HE DIDN'T RESPOND, HE
WAS APPLYING PANCAKE MAKEUP FOR
ANOTHER MSNBC HIT.
NOT JUST MICHAEL CLAIMED THIS,
THEY ALL SAID THAT, WATCH.
>> THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
POTENTIAL THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY INFORMATION, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
>> IF HE WAS IN POSSESSION OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, THOSE ARE
BY DEFINITION, POTENTIALLY
HARMFUL TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO HAS PLAYED
FAST AND LOOSE WITH THE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> WE HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
WHAT HE WAS DOING WAS DANGEROUS
TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> EZ THAT ARE CLASSIFIED AND
REALLY A THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> THAT REALLY JUMPS OUT TO ME
AS A NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
>> THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
CRIES.
>> EXTREME RISK TRUMP WAS
WILLING TO TAKE WITH OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THE FUNNIEST PART WAS
BERNSTEIN, "WASHINGTON POST" WHO
PARTICIPATED IN AN FBI
OPERATION, DOCUMENTED, TO DRIVE
A SITTING DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT
FROM OFFICE, AND HE IS LECTURING
US ABOUT KEEPING SECRET THINGS
SECRET.
LAST NIGHT WE LEARNED JOE BIDEN,
SOMEONE WITH NO POWER TO
DECLASSIFY ANYTHING WHEN HE WAS
VICE PRESIDENT STASHED
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS IN HIS
PRIVATE OFFICE AT THE SAME TIME
HE WAS SENDING DOJ AFTER DONALD
TRUMP.
CNN TROTTED OUT LAWYER CALLED
BRIAN GRIER, TO SAY THIS HAPPENS
ALL THE TIME.
>> ALMOST ANY MISHANDLING CASE
COULD BE SHOE HORNED INTO A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, BUT
GOING BACK TO THE PRIOR POINT,
THIS TYPE OF MISHANDLING HAPPENS
ALL THE TIME AND IT HAS BECOME A
POLITICAL FOOTBALL WITH ALL
THREE LAST PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES, I WORRY ABOUT WHY WE
NEED TO TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY, I
WORRY ABOUT OVERCRIMINALIZING
IT, LAUFRPING FULL
INVESTIGATIONS THAT BECOME
POLITICAL FOOTBALL AND CAN
DISINCENTIVIZE PEOPLE FROM
SERVING IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE WANT THEM TO DO THE RIGHT
THING, REPORT IT WHEN IT HAPPENS
AND NOT CONCEAL AND OBSTRUCT,
WHICH IS WHAT TRUMP DID.
>> SOME WHO WORK IN CABLE NEWS
FOR 25 YEARS CAN AFFIRM IT
WASN'T ALWAYS THE CASE THERE WAS
AN FBI EMPLOYEE TELLING YOU WHAT
THE TRUTH IS, NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
USED TO ASSUME IF SOMEONE WAS
PAID TO LIE FOR THE GOVERNMENT,
THEY PROBABLY WERE NOT RELIABLE
ON TV, PROBABLY WEREN'TS TELLING
THE TRUTH TO TV, BUT NOW IT IS
THE NORM.
CIA LAWYER YOU SAW, BRIAN GREER,
WAS TELLING US THAT DONALD TRUMP
ENDANGERED NATIONAL SECURITY,
INTELEIENCE AGENCIES HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO ASSUME A
COMPROMISE AND TAKE PROACTIVE
MEASURES TO PROTECT SOURCES AND
COLLECTION CAPABILITIES.
THAT WAS THEN, LIKE AUGUST.
NOW HE'S TELLING YOU THIS
HAPPENS ALL THE TIME ISSUE JUST
CALM DOWN.
REST OF THE NEWS MEDIA HAS BEEN
BRAZEN AND "WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTED THE CASE WILL DRAW
COMPARISON TO MAR-A-LAGO BUT
APPEARS TO BE QUITE DIFFERENT.
HOW?
EVERY NEWS SOURCE TELLING US
THERE WERE 10 DOCUMENTS, HOW DO
THEY KNOW THAT?
THEY HAVE NO IDEA, THEY ARE JUST
TAKING BIDEN'S LAWYERS WORD FOR
IT.
THAT IS NOT NEWS COLLECTION,
THAT IS PRESS RELEASE WRITING.
YOU WILL SEE IDENTICAL ARTICLES
IN FORBES AND BUSINESS INSIDER
AND THE HILL, USUAL PLACES
REPEATING SAME SCRIPTED TALKING
POINT.
WHAT THE OUTLETS TELL YOU ARE
TRUE, JOE BIDEN WAS NOT HOLDING
ON TO THE COCKTAIL NAPKINS FOUND
AT MAR-A-LAGO, HE HAD ACTUAL
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ABOUT A
BUNCH OF COUNTRY, INCLUDING
UKRAINE FROM HIS TIME AS VICE
PRESIDENT.
WHY?
WHY ALWAYS ABOUT UKRAINE?
DON'T TALK ABOUT THE BIOLAB,
WHAT IS THAT?
WHY THE OBSESSION WITH UKRAINE
GOING BACK LONG BEFORE THE
RUSSIAN INVASION 'VE UKRAINE,
GOING BACK MANY YEARS?
IN THIS CASE, THREE DAYS BEFORE
JOE BIDEN LEFT HIS JOB AS VICE
PRESIDENT IN JANUARY OF 2017,
THE UVAI
KRAINIANS WE
ABOUT THE FOCUS ON THEIR
COUNTRY.
THERE WAS A REPORT THAT SAID
THIS, LITERALLY ON THE LAST DAYS
OF HIS TERM, JOE BIDEN IS GOING
TO KYIV, HOW DO WE EXPLAIN THIS
ATTENTION TO US?
UKRAINIANS WERE CONFUSED.
WHY IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SPENDING HIS LIFE
FOCUSED ON UKRAINE?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
HERE IS ONE EXPLANATION?
SAME MOMENT THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
VISITING UKRAINE AS HIS LAST
OFFICIAL ACT, HUSBAND
DRUG-ADDICTED SON WERE ON THE
BOARD OF BURISMA, NATURAL GAS
COMPANY IN UKRAINE.
HUNTER BIDEN HELD THAT JOB UNTIL
2018.
IS THERE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
FACT HIS SON WAS GETTING RICH
FOR UKRAINE AND JOE BIDEN 2017
TRIP TO UKRAINE ON AIR FORCE TWO
AT YOUR EXPENSE?
YOU THINK THERE MIGHT BE A
CONNECTION, NO ONE IN WASHINGTON
HAS THOUGHT TO PRESS THAT POINT,
THEY ARE SET AND TALKING ABOUT
TRUMP AND HIS CRIMES.
WATCH JOE BIDEN FROM SEPTEMBER
EXPLAIN WHY HE SUPPORTED DOJ
RAID ON MAR-A-LAGO AND HERE IS A
HINT, IT IS TOTALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE FOR GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS TO KEEP CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AFTER LEAVING OFFICE.
>> WHEN YOU SAW THE PHOTOGRAPH
OF THE TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS LAID
OUT ON THE FLOOR AT MAR-A-LAGO,
WHAT DID YOU THINK TO YOURSELF
LOOKING AT THAT IMAGE?
>> HOW THAT COULD POSSIBLY
HAPPEN.
HOW ANYONE COULD BE THAT
IRRESPONSIBLE.
I THOUGHT, WHAT DATA WAS IN
THERE THAT MAY COMPROMISE
SOURCES AND METHODS, BY THAT I
MEAN NAMES OF PEOPLE, ETCETERA.
JUST TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> SO THEY SEEM LIKE HYPOCRITES,
WE COULD PLAY ENDLESS LOOP OF
CLIPS LIKE THAT, THEY ARE NOT
HYPOCRITES, THEY CAN DO WHAT
THEY WANT AND YOU ARE SUBJECTS
TO THE MINUTIA OF LEGAL CODE, IT
IS CALLED TYRANNY.
TO MORE ENDURING QUESTIONS, WHAT
IS THIS PENN BIDEN CENTER, THE
PENN BIDEN CENTER, WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF THE CENTER?
APRIL OF 2000EN SKA, ONE OF
HUNTER BIDEN BUSINESS ASSOCIATES
EXPLAINED TO HUNTER THAT PENN
BIDEN CENTER OPERATES LIKE THE
CLINTON GLOBAL INITIATIVE
WITHOUT THE MONEY RAISED.
ALL THE UPSIDE, NONE OF THE
DOWNSIDE?
WITHOUT MONEY RAISED?
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO RAISE MONEY.
WASHINGTON FREE BEACON REPORTED
THERE WAS A LOT OF MONEY BEING
RAISED BY UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA AND BEING RAISED
FROM FOREIGN GOVERNMENT AFTER
THE BIDEN CENTER OPENED.
SEE THE CONNECTION QUOTING FROM
THE PIECE, FOREIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
TO UNIVERSITIES OF PENNSYLVANIA
TRIPLED SINCE THE SOFT OPENING,
FROM 31 MILLION TO 100 MILLION
IN 2019.
WHERE DID THE MONEY COME FROM?
WHERE DO YOU THINK?
THE LARGEST FOREIGN CONTRIBUTOR
WAS CHINA.
GO TO THE WEB PAGE FOR THE PENN
BIDEN CENTER, YOU GET AN IDEA
WHAT THE MONEY BOUGHT.
SECTION CALLED ADDRESSING THREAT
TO LIBERAL INTERNATIONAL ORDER,
RUSSIA AND VLADAMIR PUTIN ARE
MENTIONED AS THREAT TO LIBERAL
INTERNATIONAL ORDER, BUT CHINA,
WHO IS COMMITTING GENOCIDE IS
NOT MENTIONED.
SO ALL THIS AROUSED SUSSPICIONS
AND WE DECIDED TO GET A CLOSER
LOOK AT UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA AND TIES TO CHINA.
WE TOOK A LOOK AT TEXT MESSAGES
FROM HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP AND
FOUND MESSAGES BETWEEN PROFESSOR
AT PENN'S DEPARTMENT TO NAOMI
BIDEN.
DEAR NAOMI, I WANT TO INVITE YOU
TO TAKE PART IN A MAJOR
CONFERENCE IN CHINA AT END OF
MARCH, I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
RECRUIT A PROMINENT YOUNG
LEADER.
THEY WILL FLY YOU BUSINESS CLASS
AND SUPPLY YOUR ACCOMMODATIONS,
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN YOU
THANKS TO YOUR FAMILY NAME.
I
WOULD NOT TAKE OFFENSE TO THAT,
BETTER YOU THAN TIFFANY TRUMP,
IF YOU ARE INTERESTED, CAN YOU
SEND ME A BIO, I WOULD FORWARD
THAT AND EXPECT A FORMAL
INVITATION.
PRETTY REMARKABLE.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN PREVIOUSLY
REPORTED, AS FAR AS WE KNOW.
EMPLOYEE OF UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, IVY LEAGUE SCHOOL,
SENDING AN INVITATION ON BEHALF
OF THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
TO RECRUIT JOE BIDEN'S
GRANDDAUGHTER, SHE WOULD STAY IN
GOVERNMENT CONTROLLED
ACOMMENDATIONS.
PEOPLE ON TELEVISION SEEM
CONCERNED ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY, FORMER CIA AND FBI
EMPLOYEES GOING ON CNN AND MSNBC
TO TELL YOU NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATION ARE FIRST IN MIND,
ARE THEY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS?
THEY ASKED A SINGLE QUESTION
ABOUT IT?
OF COURSE THEY WON'T.
TONIGHT WE'LL ASK FACT-BASED
QUESTIONS ABOUT CLASSIFIED